once again wildfires are ravaging
California and the president is doing
what no president should be doing which
is vowing no more federal aid to
California at this key time Trump and
right-wingers have been using the
California wildfires to spread what is a
combination of anti-science nonsense but
also sort of like the most toxic version
of partisan politics that you can
imagine which is when people's lives are
at stake I actually saw a clip last week
a Fox News hosts Tucker Carlson and
cultural critic Dave Rubin saying you
can blame the wildfires on left wing
woke nests and political correctness
Trump has previously said all sorts of
nonsense about the wildfires as well
including how this is all the fault of
forest management which he has no idea
what that even means the latest fires
are really bad the last I looked over
200,000 acres of land destroyed people
fleeing homes 115 hundred and 25 maybe a
structures that have been damaged by the
fires at least three people killed so
far that number sadly maybe climbing so
what does Donald Trump do he tweets
insults at the California Governor Gavin
Newsom and says no more aid for
California quote the Governor of
California Gavin Newsom has done a
terrible job of forest management I told
him from the first day we met that he
must clean his forest floors regardless
of what his bosses the environmentalists
demand of him must also do burns and cut
fire stoppers every year as the fires
rage fire apostrophe s by the way as the
fires rage the rage belonging to the
fires and California burns it is the
same thing and then he comes to the
federal government for money help no
more get your act together governor you
don't see close to the level of burn in
other states yeah because their
circumstances are totally different
topographically but our teams are
putting are working well together in
putting these massive many fires out
great firefighters also open up the
ridiculously closed water lanes coming
down from the north don't pour it out
into the Pacific Ocean should be done
immediately California desperately needs
water and
can have it now gavin newsom immediately
shooting back on twitter that trumps
shouldn't even really be talking about
this because he doesn't even accept
climate science saying quote you don't
believe in climate change you are
excused from there from this
conversation so there's a lot here
that's sick now of course if you're the
president and you tell a state one of
the states that you were also the
president for you tell a state that's
suffering from horrible wildfires that
you're cutting off aid
it's disgusting people are dying
literally because of the fires second
Trump talking about water lanes from the
north this guy has no idea what he's
talking about I mean truly no idea he's
referring to these rules that don't
allow farmers to drain all the water
from rivers and you have to let some of
the water flow into the oceans naturally
as the planet is supposed to work and
Donald Trump is apparently furious with
that he thinks it's some kind of leftist
mismanagement to allow rivers to
function normally Donald Trump is then
using people's homes and property and
lives their lives here being lost to be
flippant about climate change and to
throw political retribution at a state
that he doesn't like it has a Democratic
governor he's constantly embattled with
Nancy Pelosi congresswoman from
California but California is filled with
both Democrats and Republicans not that
should even matter not that it should
even make a difference because they're
all Americans I hope that historians are
properly documenting everything of that
that is taking place here so that the
sick and vile nature of this
administration isn't lost to history
because that would be a tragedy the
administration is tragic its actions are
tragic but forgetting the horrors of
this administration would also be tragic
and if this guy wins re-election this
exact kind of pettiness although it
sounds to call it pettiness is too soft
right it's more than pettiness is worse
than that this is what we would expect
to be in overdrive if Donald Trump is
reelected and knows that he doesn't have
another election to win or to deal with
at the tail-end is this how cheap life
has become under Donald Trump homeless
children kids and cages who cares there
are political points to score fires are
killing people well the governor is a
Democrat
and some something-something rivers and
the ocean no more aid for you it's
horrifying and imagine what lessons our
kids are being taught implicitly by this
president when you have a president that
behaves this way and children see it
what lessons are we teaching kids based
on the behavior of this madman truly sad
and hopefully without Trump's help they
can get the Wildfire situation under
control in California